hey poppy here it's Papa John and you're
listening to the h3 podcast go Ethan go
ela welcome everybody to the first
episode of the h3 quarantine experience
mean ela are locked securely in our
apocalypse bunker here we had Dan slave
away to build us this beautiful home
studio to shoot the Pug that's because
the show must go on what song is that
keep going oh I don't know why you
didn't ring a bell for me no Dan did a
wonderful job coming here and putting
this together you know we weren't
planning on doing this we wanted to do
our social distancing unfortunately had
Bert Kreischer who I love his new
special is out he was coming to promote
that which is on Netflix yeah but let's
promote it anyway yeah that's what I'm
kind of doing what it's called like Big
Boi or some [ __ ] was it it's on that I
just I mean just like Bert Kreischer on
Netflix you know it's probably on your
homepage anyway but um I was very much
looking forward to that he I mean he's
he's one of the greatest guests funniest
guy but we had to say it was just
getting too crazy out there it's so
crazy and it's only getting crazier
every day yeah everything is closing
yeah it's it's you know and I figure
there's so many people at home right now
the time to work is now the time to
entertain to work like our kind of yeah
yes entertain the people we must keep
more out hi that is our duty to society
keep the morale high or in or in some
cases keep them around low which I also
have that effect on people as well so
how do you feel about sweating the
curves Podcast flatten the curve you
want to rename with that uh hmm I like
it yeah
catchy flatten the curve baby so uh Oh
today's episode is sponsored by kaptara
Thank You Sara
the official sponsor of the apocalypse
no we love kaptara they would never
respond to the apocalypse Oh
unfortunately PewDiePie was actually he
was meant to come into the studio two
day which is crazy because I just said
Bert was no but but actually I'm just
getting mixed up PewDiePie was supposed
to be on today and because of the
quarantine and all the laws and
restrictions in California I had to
cancel the episode we're just totally
crazy because he's out here just for the
show it's unbelievable I know it's on
it's so coincidental so I have my
deepest condolences to PewDiePie for
having to bump him today it wasn't my
fault it was the quarantine but we will
have him on as soon as we can I think
next week he'll call in via Skype okay
but ela can I share my current mood with
you Sharon I saw this on Instagram and I
was like oh man there's like I've seen
several things like the they say the war
horses of the Apocalypse they say
there's like 4 Horsemen of the
Apocalypse ok so one of them is this
video that just popped up in my feed
like yesterday or three days ago yeah
man when this when this guy doesn't
smile it trips me out
do you think he's doing this because the
apocalypse him commenting on current
events right he's like bro listen I got
a chop
I got a chopped cabbage right now but
I'm not gonna be happy about it just get
a look at this man
cz and Buraq will be fine dude is that
his resting face though cuz he or is he
looking sad thing is the resting face is
smiling right dot things are dire when
C's Ian's not smiling
liesl chopping uh chopping the day he
stops chopping then we'll know we're
really not sure so that was one Horsemen
of the Apocalypse the other Horsemen of
the Apocalypse was uh let me find this
other one this video of Sarah Palin on
Dancing with the Stars was the other
Horsemen of the Apocalypse which I am
currently unable to find this may not be
able to find it is the third Horseman of
the Apocalypse oh here it is so I'm
gonna have to mute this one please don't
autoplay please don't autoplay please
don't how to play don't hit me don't
play me like don't do me dirty like that
okay I got it so oh it's big it's it's a
I got big butts and I cannot lie that's
what she's doing so here comes sailor
Sarah Palin who was once upon a time
almost our vice president and the
governor of Alaska here on Dancing with
the Stars - I like big butts and I
cannot lie I mean what I mean
they must I mean god I guess they must
pay them just enough for this to be
worth it I don't know it's like so not
age-appropriate this is like I would
even feel too old to wear that well what
they it's like they scientifically
calculate this to humiliate them as much
as possible
and they must pay them they must just
pay them enough to make embarrassment
and like how much could they be paying a
couple hundred thousand or something
like that no way you get anyone on stage
that's probably good paycheck yeah what
I go into a new starts for 200,000 yeah
consider or not yeah it's in my
wheelhouse I do it for less I do you
wear this kind of spice it's not up to
me they're like okay like oh you thought
you were coming here to be funny and do
your bit no here's an outfit that is
gonna they figure it out scientifically
to how to humiliate and the most yeah
that's definitely an apocalypse video so
this is the second Horsemen of the
Apocalypse God you do you remember the
Sarah Palin thing you were in America at
the time but no I don't but I only know
the situation video with her daughter oh
yeah this logic so Sarah Palin Mike are
not my pence
longa Rangga Republican John McCain who
recently passed away was running for
president and many people think that's
ultimately the demise of his campaign he
picked Sarah Palin for his VP which was
just pretty I mean I guess they crunched
the numbers and they like the what it
did but it was weird cuz a lot of people
was like the Sarah Palin horn going
around Oh God there was like Sarah Palin
look-alikes and like I mean everywhere
it was all Sarah Palin portent for like
a year but the thought of her being
president if John McCain like bid it
so that's Sarah Palin shout-out to her
so that was the second so it we're the
apocalypse is clearly upon us and those
are the I've only found two
unfortunately so those are the two I've
found ya but ya know ya there you go
good observation you know but we are on
quarantine Teddy fresh basically we've
shut it down I mean we sent over our
employees home yeah and see what it's
like every day becomes worse like at
first we said okay no working from the
office and we're like well maybe some
stores at the mall are gonna close cuz
we also sell to zoomies but online will
probably continue and then now it's like
online is probably gonna close too cuz
you know it's only a matter of time
before people can't go shipping stuff or
packing stuff right well our fulfillment
service who does the shipping for us
they're in a they're in a big warehouse
so right now our website is online but
I'm assuming it's only a matter of time
before I think that I think the state
will eventually issue a mandate ordering
everyone to close in fact one of our
manufacturers in Orange County was just
issued a mandate by the county that they
have to stop which also I starting to
work with them was another way of trying
to help the situation cuz we were almost
doing everything in China at the time
like a few months back and we started to
think like how can we get out of China
and diversify ourselves and also just
work with other places do some stuff
here in other countries and so we found
this great place here for printing
t-shirts and anything printables and so
we were like okay if China is closing
because of the virus we still got this
place you're gonna be fine they're
closed thank you I gotta say I called it
I said when this
should start first of all people need to
if this is nothing else other than this
means nothing else other than that
people need to listen to me more right
everywhere around the world I mean every
single human being sometimes yes but I
mean a lot of people were accusing me of
fear-mongering I did a podcast episode
this on a lot of a long time ago about
you need to be more and everyone thought
I was crazy and I but I have to say I
didn't expect it even I was getting a
little concerned with you because you
were like on Twitter all day and you
started to look like one of those
conspiracy people and sending everyone
links like look at this look at this
it's gonna be crazy and everyone was
like whatever it's fine we're in America
we got this yeah but it definitely
sounded awful like nothing about it
sounded you know made up but it was just
so it's crazy to believe it's
far-fetched yeah but the thing is that
there's this paradox when it comes to
pandemics it's like when the appropriate
time to react when you react accordingly
it seems to the general public and
everyone that you're overreacting and
it's ridiculous and you're irresponsible
but then when it's too late to react
then when everyone wants to react it's
already way too late to contain it so
that's that is an inherent problem with
responding to pandemic it's hard to
react to something you haven't seen you
know like well even now people are
flipping about it they go and then they
say in the United States uh there's only
one or two hundred deaths like whoa I
mean the experts are predicting that
there's going to be a million plus a
million to five million deaths in the
United States depending on depending on
how many hospital beds we can make
available how many
what do you could the breathing
apparatus the APUs what do you call
those I've been reading a million times
anyway the things that help you breathe
when you can't breathe for yourself
because the lungs is what this
particular virus does
so it all depends on on like the whole
point of the quarantine is to like as
you said flatten the curve flatten the
curve too many people get sick at one
time the hospitals get slammed
and then basically that's when the
mortality rate goes from like 1% up to
like you know because they can't treat
people right people who should who'd be
easy to keep them alive and treat them
or all the sudden they don't have access
to a hospital bed or breathing apparatus
and then it's like up there dead for no
reason and then the other problem is
when all these breathing apparatuses are
in use and all the hospital beds are
full I mean there's people like let's
say there's no virus there's people who
need that care already who are who are
now not gonna be able to get it yeah so
it's it turns into a really a cluster a
mother-effing cluster F for some reason
I feel like I don't want to curse in
this room but in the pot I'll curse like
a all day long is it because we're home
and Theodore is here it could be
something I think it's something about
being home does really but I was like
like I was like mother I don't know why
this feels like a more wholesome place
yeah so you know I have I have a chronic
cough as many of you have noticed
throughout the years but now it has
steel Vaughn pointed out on Twitter
Krishna coughing is the new N word so I
feel like I'm the most racist male alive
because I have this chronic coughing I
feel I'm sorry it's not the fire I have
a chronic condition but I even start
getting a my own head and I'm and I
start coughing like the other day I
started coughing and we were we were
moving all this [ __ ] down into into this
room to set up the podcast and I started
sweating I was feeling warmth and I was
like oh [ __ ]
so I went upstairs and I took my
temperature yeah it's like you get on
your head my temperature was fine
102 102 was my temperature which is the
normal time no I'm just kidding 98 so
you know it's a series and this is just
surreal what it is
so just weird all of a sudden I'm
talking to my mom in Israel and we're
all in the same boat you know what I
mean it's so weird like she's usually
things will be different I don't know
whatever we're dealing with here she's
not dealing with there and now it's like
I'm calling her and she's like what do
we do
I'm at home I can't go anywhere she
wants she wanted to go to my sister
because she has three little kids so she
wanted to hang out with them and my
sister was like no you can't come I
don't want you to come cuz it's too
dangerous for you well so yeah wish my
mom was that safe my mom's like has all
these pre-existing conditions she's like
she's like the perfect person of when
they say people who are old and with
pre-existing conditions need to stay at
home she's the exact person they're
talking to and she goes you know she
went to do she went to Kay uh TJ Maxx
yeah TJ Maxx she's like don't worry I
was wearing gloves and a mask I was like
you're gonna die you were gonna die see
people don't take it seriously but
unfortunately the people who were all
flipping about it now in two or three
weeks when thick when the cases are Max
and the mortality rate is going up then
all the sudden people are going to
understand that it's actually very
serious and by that time all the people
went out to the bars and the restaurants
you were trying to party and be like if
the corona parts I'm young and I'm
American they're gonna realize just how
dangerous what they what they did what
yeah but it'll be too late
they're already caused the harm but but
in a way I can't I can't blame them in a
way because it's just stuff it's
inconceivable right and it's it's so
hard to put everything on pause and not
leave the house all of a sudden like
it's just so crazy it's so hard to
really come to terms with what it really
means like you think okay I won't go to
work but then there's like this other
thing that you're used to doing for some
people it's the gym people are like well
I could still exercise right and that's
like no you can't not do anything well
luckily for me everything I don't leave
the house oh right it's kind of good
thing the coffee is not disrupted at all
I can totally see what you're saying
totally
and you know I was listening to a
podcast with these scientists and
they're saying there's anything good
that comes out of this it's that this is
a dress rehearsal for the real one
because this one real one there could be
a pandemic and that's equally contagious
that has a 60% mortality rate what that
will just destroy society because well
what I'm saying is that this that kind
of people have been drumming the are
people blasting the siren and science
community saying the epidemic is
inevitable we have to prepare for a
pandemic really but because of our lack
of imagination of foresight and I think
global warming is the same thing we know
it's coming but it's just not real
enough and all of a sudden when it
smacks you in the face you can't react
so the potential for a pandemic that's
just as contagious as this with a 60%
mortality rate it's possible
and these pandemics seem to be happening
like once every 100 years the last one
that happens like the span in nineteen
something 1912 or some [ __ ] I don't know
the exact date but I hope that we as a
society can learn and prepare for this
but I just don't know in a hundred years
if people will still I feel it for 20
years maybe it's like World War two the
world wars it's like everyone was so
guarded and and they were so
appreciative of the trauma that the
world went through but now 19 you know
1939 is when the war started or 1942
you know how long has it been now 60 80
years so it's like people start to get
over it you start to see these tensions
boiling again we forget the lessons we
learn because people who lived and died
for that we're incapable of caring that
I guess they might do like an
international day of remembering what
happened yeah but how long is that last
for World War two as well yeah you see
the same conflicts flaring up now right
I guess it's just it's the nature of the
nature of being human exactly what you
do so ultimately I mean
I don't know what to do because I oughta
me that I feel like are inherent it's
inevitable that we just forget it's like
when you're sick with the fever right
and it's so awful the worst thing ever
and then when you're better two weeks
later you completely forget what it's
like to be sick yeah and so I think I
think it's gonna end up being our demise
unfortunately is that we can't remember
the trauma we can't remember the trauma
in it it's kind of great you know
cuz if you you gotta be able to function
on a daily basis if you remember all the
trauma and everything that's a very good
part of our survival probably that's
very that's absolutely a good
observation but ultimately what do you I
don't know it's skip but date those have
scared the freaking crap out of me when
they were like yeah I can't I can't hang
with those scientists people first of
all the way they think they're so aware
of everything yeah like this other
potential of a way worse flu I've been
thinking about opening I can I don't
wanna know that stuff you know what I
mean I'm trying to leave my life well
you know I'd rather not know remember
the first time you learned that like an
asteroid could just wipe out all life on
Earth all right like a gamma-ray burst
you know about gamma-ray bursts no when
a star blows up it shoots gamma rays
which is the most powerful single beam
of energy in the whole universe there's
a chance that a beam crosses earth and
will just vaporize all of Earth yeah
no warning not nothing to do it just
watch this if even they've even
theorized that it's already happened and
that accounts for one of the massive
stations that had happened on earth well
I just I don't know cuz you could at the
same way it's or at the same time you
could also just walk down the street and
someone will run into you and you'll die
so like what are you supposed to do with
this information you know what I mean
yeah I think well for them well that's a
little different mean for them they just
want to see Society humanity as a
species being smarter about preserving
our own fate yeah no I mean I don't mean
to disregard scientists I think they're
well we don't have we're just plebs do
they're annoying like I wish that our
government would only listen or them
right now our government the people who
are in charge of us need to listen to
these people and prepare accordingly you
know not our job on with what the hell
yeah I'm an entertainer goddammit
I'm here to entertain and make you
fearful well quarantine so happy
quarantine everybody all of our
employees are being paid by the way just
stupid throw that out there everyone's
working from home and we're paying
everybody throughout the quarantine and
by the way that made us think about
people are now losing their job like
what are you supposed to do you all of a
sudden you have grandparents that are
still do I don't know it's just insane
yeah if I was um there's a lot of people
in Hollywood cuz Hollywood works on all
this freelance work right now guys and
video guys and like guys and they all go
from gig to gig now everything's shut
down and these poor guys have no no
income all of a sudden and I'll be
honest there's I mean III don't even
know how long this could last I don't
think it's gonna be a couple works I I
personally think it's gonna be a couple
of months there are people are gonna be
in their [ __ ] houses Oh II just did
that for I take it back
and you should listen to me cuz I'm
right all the time right ela I was right
a my fear I was right even my brother
who's a know-it-all thought I was acting
crazy but you know what it was about
this virus that scared me was the fact
that it was contagious right while you
were asymptomatic that was that's what
more like this week's yes that's what
makes this virus so so contain so tricky
and hard to do I mean
they say we're all gonna get it already
percent 80% pretty much everyone
you know the UK they're like UK may have
had a worst response to it than than the
you know United States the UK goes we're
just gonna do herd immunity because we
can't possibly stop the wave flatten the
curve so we just want everyone to get
infected and then you become immune so
like just go out do your thing with your
life and then they're like then they
realized a few days ago they're like
this is awful we can't do this Wow it's
good it's gonna be catastrophic so then
they quarantine everyone but boy they
really messed that one up you know
what's funny you're saying that like
your mom is having the same experience
as you I was thinking usually when
there's this level of catastrophe in the
United States you expect all these
terrorists like celebrating in [ __ ] big
the terror sir they're also getting sick
yeah this it's amazing because it
affects everyone the same exact way and
we were like doesn't matter if you have
money or you don't I mean I guess it
does in a way cuz if you have money you
can still pay rent but regardless of
that you get sick from it you get sick
you stuff to quarantine as well you
still can't do anything yeah there's no
rich managed force oh yeah doesn't
matter what religion you are you know
it's funny last week I was like I want
to have a quarantine free episode I
don't want to talk about the corona
virus
I just want to entertain the people but
now we're in our basement everybody
everybody is stuck in their house in the
whole freaking world how do you not
we're not it yeah you guys want my heart
aches anyways let's be honest and don't
even get me started on Trump I'm just
kidding I'm not gonna go there no
politics actually I'm I'm I have to say
I'm I'm kind of proud of Trump this week
because he has actually expressed his
eagerness to adopt Sir Andrew Yang's
policy of new bi yeah of giving he
reportedly he's on board with the idea
of giving every American $1,000 a month
or more I heard that's the figure I
heard I heard other people float 2,000 a
month that's a lot that's all people
need it I mean that that's amazing I'm
saying I can live lay it even a dozen
doesn't pay you're right no not even
close but I'll buy you food you know
this the thing is they suspended their I
think the president said that they're
suspending eviction and and mortgage
defaults for the time being so nobody's
gonna get kicked out of their house at
the very least for now yeah it's gonna
be tough because like Andrew Andrew
Young was talking about how if you're
getting now and that even when the virus
is over you still have that that you
know it's just gonna really well we top
we have to figure that out yeah we gotta
figure that out you know you know and I
and I keep hearing these like the
airline businesses complaining they're
gonna go out of business
[ __ ] the airline business if you're
irresponsible can't run your business
but our businesses aren't going out of
business these guys been making billions
of dollars it's because their cost is
insane so if they don't fly they can't
maintain it I've heard it's because
they've been buying their own stocks
back and they've been price gouging
making a shitload of money and they're
here and they've been investing it
irresponsibly I'm sure their costs are
high I don't I just think that they
cannot it's not like you can just float
in a company like that without actually
flying and making I don't know they make
a lot of money well the thing is you
have the planes landed okay so you're
not paying for fuel well maintenance of
those things it's crazy
I think they lease the planes to that's
like a huge cost they don't buy them
outright cuz they're like each plane
cost so much I'd like to learn more
about this because we have a conflicting
thing on this I don't know but I'm very
don't know either I'm very hesitant to
bail out some more bin
don't take anything we say here as if we
really think we know why are you talking
about it at all right I don't know why
probably should I don't like the idea of
reeling out more big businesses if they
you might be regula but I've heard that
they've been abusing their huge profits
they've been making they have been
buying back their own stock with the
huge amount of profits and depleting
their cash reserves I think I just don't
like to believe that everyone is so evil
in the world
these are huge corporations they all run
like mafia maybe they all just that's
not my first that's not the first place
I go to in my mind okay thank you I'll
give them the benefit of the doubt first
you give me the airlines that bevor the
doubt those mother effers who charge you
like $100 per bag and they don't you
flying you across the country or
whatever across the globe but they
didn't used to charge you for it they
put you in the backseat you really think
that the seat in the very back next to
the bathroom that doesn't recline is the
same value as the seat in front of it I
hate those guys the benefit if I get
that seat again I will just not fly I've
had that it was the worst flight so I'm
saying it shouldn't be you shouldn't
charge the same amount that I there you
go you see you won't trust them Fran
topic no way that's cuz of scum oh just
so you know you're so sorry they
interrupt oh we gotta go to break let's
just read it
we have only one sponsor today times are
tough here guys kaptara though we love
kaptara kaptara is the okay so kaptara
is a website that they aggregate tons of
different softwares for you so that you
can quickly search and filter options to
find the features and the pricing you
need compare your top choices side by
side and save your favorites and with
free in-depth software guides and tools
plus over 1 million reviews from people
like
you kaptara gives you access to
everything you need to know before you
buy
the software of your dreams so spend
less time trying to find software and
more time doing what you do best find
the right software for you fine go find
the right software for you at kaptara
comm slash h3 that's not the end it's
only the middle but it's true there's so
many different kinds of software's in
the world each one tailored so
specifically to your needs the right
software can make all the difference in
your life and your business and your
dreams that's right there's a software
out there that you know exists right now
that will life hack because someone has
already been there and they've already
thought about it
and they're way smarter and they already
made a software resolved it yeah bro you
know what life hacks are that's what
kaptara is it's a life hack for your
dreams should should be their slogan so
here we go you want no more cap about
kaptara kaptara is your business a lie
it's a free online resource to help you
find the best software solutions for you
for your unique work needs search more
than 700 specific categories of software
everything from project management to
email marketing to all the way to yoga
studio management software and again
that always shocks me that doesn't thing
but that's just proves my point
how niche they are here from people like
you with over 1 million reviews of
products from verified users no matter
what kind of software your business
needs kaptara makes it easy to discover
the right solution fast join the
millions of people who use kaptara each
month to find the right tools for their
business so go to kaptara comm /a sharif
for free today to find the right
software choice for your business
kaptara comm / h tree that's kaptara
spelled c AP ter are a.com slash h3
that's kaptara software selection
simplified how was that great nice where
were we under the world
what was it oh I was like what was that
let's just sit on this for a little bit
yeah so we are talking about corona yada
yada yada
everything's fricked I was wondering
such a hater but what can I do I mean
how can you trust the airlines sure the
airlines there baby there right longer
oh and assume pharmaceutical companies
oh really in terms of evilness don't
know anything probably I don't know in
it I don't know anything about it well
to be fair I don't know it I don't know
either I should just sit here while
you're looking it up what do you search
I don't even know what to search yeah do
airlines suck question mark our airline
company is evil there you go I'll wait
good our airline companies evil
you
coming up our airline company's evil Oh
are they evil no yes or no and the
answer is what's the answer undecided
just the podcast contest Thank You
Compton learn in love headline they were
born 660 billion in government aid for
aerospace industry hit by them don't you
think that the people of the people like
60 billion let's give that to the people
dude
bowling doesn't need 60 billion Boeing
can [ __ ] off into oblivion someone else
will fill the void who's less you're
responsible bowling by the way made a
plane that the software literally forces
it to crash into the earth remember that
yeah that's why they're in trouble well
they're cutting corners that's what you
know what I mean right
so that go ahead the conclusion is
I'm wondering what's Jeff Bezos to write
it's like alright just bail everyone out
just give us about a hundred thirty
million dollars give some blanks to some
people I'll take a Boeing yeah he's got
a hundred thirty billion you're like
okay you know not all rich people are
evil let's see what you can do for us I
mean we're in a time of crisis our
government has you know screwed the
pooch a little bit on the testing let's
see what you've got quiet from Jeff
Bezos I feel like Jeff Bezos has a moral
responsibility to his society that has
built him up and made him the wealthiest
man who ever lived he knew where is Jeff
Bezos where is Jeff
well so far Amazon is still working to
which doesn't make any sense yeah
because all the worker dude it's not
cool Amazon's gonna shut down the
warehouse once it's gonna happen it's
gonna shut down but he's got all of his
workers working overtime I've seen a
lots of articles of people complain that
the conditions are not safe he really
seems more and more evil every week
listening to this policy at Whole Foods
which is owned by Amazon they say have
me read this to you this shocked me to
my to my core
Whole Foods wants workers to help pay
some colleagues sick leave during the
coronavirus as Amazon corporate offers
two weeks well here it says I was
looking at here's a here's a quote and a
letter sent to employees earlier this
week from the Whole Foods CEO John
Mackey he says one option available to
workers was for them to donate their
paid time off days to a pool that other
workers could draw from what yeah Amazon
owned Whole Foods is telling its
employees to donate their own paid time
off I mean now is the time use your
hordes of money because guess what if we
all die in society become
functionally you don't get to make money
anymore either if you want to think
about it from selfish place but Jeff
Bezos what are you doing to help us Jeff
if you could hear me Geoff Keighley
he can't hear me Alexa tell Jeff to help
us he can hear us he's such a super
villain bro Jeff Bezos and now he looks
more and more like let Lex Luthor are
every day where Superman
it's like we have Lex Luthor but no
Superman mm-hmm what did to him out look
young musk could have been a superhero
but he's too busy like memeing on
Twitter you feel like anyone's falling a
little bit and he's also like Corona it
up and his offices well he tweeted out a
week ago coronavirus panic is stupid so
he said panic is stupid which I guess
technically I agree with but it was
during a time when a lot of people were
like oh these people who are getting you
know but even the panic doesn't look
that stupid anymore if you can't leave
your house whoever stocked up on stuff I
understand probably happy I definitely
understand the urge and by the way all
the people that picked up on toilet
paper aren't looking that dumb cuz they
said on the mountain toilet paper yeah
although there are some incredible
stories of like this dude who he he
traveled I mean the guy saw the writing
on the wall so I guess props to him but
he traveled like between three states
and bought $18,000 with the pan
sanitizer right and then he put it all
in amazon price gouging and then amazon
removed the listing and he's just
sitting on $18,000 a nice move from
Amazon for once I guess yeah I mean but
then I was like whoa but we don't have
any hand sanitizer so it's kind of a at
the same time people need that well
anyway what ended up happening is that
the district attorney went to his
storage unit with the police and made
him donate it
he donated like a local church who's
giving it out to everyone okay so I
guess in the end but honestly okay so
this guy's trying to profit off this
what about pharmaceutical companies that
have been doing that every day yeah you
know it's easy to demonize him I'm so so
bitter right now so Jeff Bezos everybody
I mean seriously how is it crickets from
Jeff what is he doing for us
he owes our probably busy furnishing his
new 250 million dollar house that's
probably that's probably true
like dude help us with the test we don't
have tests United States doesn't have
coronavirus tests we have the lowest
tests per million people of the whole
developed world Jeff makes them tasks
you're like a manufacturing god get his
tests do something build a hospital you
could build a ha you could build 20
hospitals be a good guy god I mean how
do you waste that opportunity when you
have when you have that so much
potential to help everybody hundred
thirty billion that guy's got so much
money he's like what am I gonna do so
much money I'm gonna build Blue Origin
go to space he's like I I don't have I
have so much money I can't spend ninety
help us help everybody right that's
right getting very dark Ethan well I'm
right aren't I here's the Amazon policy
on they say effective immediately
this is they've issued this thinking
they're being all such good guys they go
effective immediately all Amazon
employees who are diagnosed with covet
19 or placed into quarantine will
receive up to two weeks of pay so they
have they're waiting until you get
diagnosed or placed into quarantine and
getting like a note of quarantine from
the governance it's like seriously you
want to wait until one of your workers
is diagnosed with the virus that means
they've already [ __ ]
right it everywhere on the packages you
guys send out back just working covered
Colin
I got packages nobody door cover two
crowbars because jeff bezos two weeks is
not gonna be enough oh I didn't know
they say up to two we worship if we can
afford to pay all of our employees like
without a limit right now we're just
told them don't worry about it you're
all being paid well I will say in our in
our in our or in the defense of other
business owners who maybe can't afford
it we are able to continue our business
I don't know about Teddy fresh that that
is probably gonna grind to a halt but at
least here are entertainments that we're
able to continue working with everyone
yeah but but for example yeah Teddy
fresh you're gonna grind to a halt and
actually we have a way of all we spend a
lot of money on on everything I mean our
costs there are really high right we
have live team employees we're not the
size of Amazon but um we're not worth
hundred thirty billion right
we're not even worth 1 billion no but I
just feel like people need to take more
responsibility as the company owners I
hundred percent agree I and then like
all these owners they have you know they
they plan for this times and they put
some money aside yeah and this is what
it's for you gotta float the company now
and that means help your workers there
are a lot of companies who are doing
good who are like go home we're gonna
pay I don't know I've I was looking at
the current is the coronavirus subreddit
and I rarely go and read it I don't know
why I ended up there I like that so it
was so dark everything was so dark but
some people there were saying their
employees are still asking them to come
to work and they're like did you not
hear the news like you even you asking
me to come in to the office like someone
was like all the work I do is on the
computer I could totally do it from home
and they're they're asking me to come in
and clock handle dogs just came storming
in hey yeah that's rough but like okay
so you have to think about this
probably a small business right I mean I
don't know if it's a big business or
small business like a small business
owners like dance there's a lot of small
businesses were like hey if you don't
come in and work I can't I can't pay ya
no I'm not I don't think that sounded
like a small business yeah I'm not
talking about small businesses I think
the small businesses are gonna get hit
the hardest
that's the people who I feel for the
most because but there are so many big
businesses and they have no excuse
yeah people like Jeff Bezos should be
pulling out the stops dude spend a
hundred billion you can make such a big
difference and everyone will love your
ass because you're a good guy and I evil
greedy order piece of [ __ ] who makes
your employees pulled their own sick
weight because your sick days you too
cheap to actually provide for them you
guys can probably hear the dogs playing
the dogs are loving the quarantine so
stay adorn yeah they're like dude this
virus is great you know they're so cute
episode it's fine okay that's as good as
any other okay I don't know it's what it
is it's a podcast right it's good yeah
I'm very upset I think you make a good
point
like I'm very upset like Jeff people
like Jeff Bezos need to take
responsibility for the welfare of their
workers and this big companies to prove
to us that you're not evil scumbag right
there are some that are there are some
that have pledged to take care of their
employees well well on sick leave but
Amazon is not one of them and what is
Facebook I mean that's a good question I
have no idea whatever he's doing I still
don't like suck Zuckerberg as rich as
Bezos pretty much psychic ability 2000
photos but he he does eve lat he doesn't
have human empathy so I wouldn't expect
much of him I don't know they gotta take
ownership company like Amazon doesn't
only owe their employees they owe
society right society are as a whole
made something like Amazon possible the
roads the Postal Service everybody
purchases Amazon you have an obligation
and this one whatever needed so [ __ ]
Amazon it's short I think they're gonna
shut down the late nights have shut down
everything on TV shut down that's why I
felt it was important to come do this
must entertain the people mm-hmm there's
a drought of content mm-hmm
I guess there's really youtube's time to
shine because every month every tubers
like that's what we do it's all good
over here you know it's weird being
without the guys though yeah love having
those guys that's weird being back in
this shot with the two of us I know it
feels very old-school ether in yellow
the difference is that on the podcasts I
know when I'm not talking they switch
off with me but yeah so that's that
let's see what else oh yeah yeah your
mom was coming too so long my brother
was gonna come to from New York actually
like moving to a new house or something
oh and they have everything packed I
guess you would just do it right but
anyway yeah cross state we moved in New
York I'm just saying there's so much
worse like there's gotta be a some
people like cross like moving to New
York City
yeah I guess you got a lot of time to
unpack now a good sign we're actually
kind of in the middle of something like
we were getting work done in our bedroom
so
we were sleeping in a different room for
the time being and it was supposed to be
almost done in April but now we're
starting being put on hold that sounds
like some bougie-ass problems yes toilet
what do you what are your thoughts on
hoarding toilet paper I mean I still
think it's stupid I just feel like
that's the worst some of those things
you would like people were like so
focused on hating on those people and
that were you know stocking up on stuff
some people were going too far well yes
they're like some people like old people
and you know whatever the disabled or
whatever the people who are gonna die
from this virus in short that by the way
as an aside I'm struck by like the
people's callousness towards old people
and what is going on old people and
people with like pre-existing questions
is going on it's like three days ago
before it became this bad people like I
saw this all the times like a really
radical push back on me like a hateful
strong pushback of people being like
it's not you'll be fine only old people
are gonna die all right and it's just
the stunning callousness okay I keep
hearing that from different people at
different ages and it's like wait what
do you not care about your parents I
don't maybe they don't understand how it
works I think they do I mean the threat
is not to you the threat is that you get
sick and then you pass it on to other
people who are have a way higher risk of
death from it but also it's not true
that it's know young people could die
for me you don't want this it's if you
have some other condition and it hits
you well there's been a lot of
misinformation even from our president
down you know that's in direct contrast
to what the CDC and fire and viral
specialists and doctors are saying so
they say you know Donald Trump tweeted
out something like hey just to let you
know fifty thousand people died from the
flu
and and nobody's panic about that just
think about it yeah he says only a
hundred people have died from this in
the USA think about that so he's telling
people effectively hey it's this thing
is not even as bad as the flu so don't
worry about it but they stopped doing
that now yeah he stopped now but that
was like several days ago yeah and
people the people he told that to who
were buying into that messaging still
kind of believe it right even though
he's changed his tune and that's the
danger of like it's very you just did
surprise with the amount of people that
are like well it only hits old people so
I'm fine I'm like how can you be so
comic-book callous and evil I mean but
even still you're okay with like I mean
people are calling it the boomer remover
yes but you see clips of people out in
bars partying you know in a second well
if I get it on I'll be fine
you know that you have a grandma or
someone old or someone with a immune
deficiency but also eventually it's
gonna affect everyone if if we don't
flood on the curb and and we overwhelmed
the hospitals you know if some healthy
people will get someone who's just got
some other condition all of a sudden
it's treatment you can't get treatment
yeah but it's like you're just affecting
everyone it's not really just old people
the big picture is that everything is
messed up no it's true
this is a rare really unprecedented in
our lifetime is that we all have a part
to play in this usually somebody else's
problem its government's problem it's
such as there's problem each person each
individual in this country in this world
has a part to play in this pandemic if
you stay at home if you limit your
interactions if you do social distancing
you will
you will make this better we all have a
role to play from top to bottom and
that's hard to understand really for a
lot of people it's just a weird time
dude there's a weird time I mean people
gonna be talking about this for hundreds
of years this is the big one this is
probably the craziest thing that's
happened in my life like if we can look
at the bright side I do feel like we can
maybe just enjoyed this like forced time
off that you have to stay at home and
obviously like I know that it comes with
a lot of negatives but I don't know I
mean I state you're saying how many
opportunities do we get a life to just
like everyone everyone like yeah you're
not working but everyone is not working
you you don't need to check your emails
there's nothing there I guess someone is
some people would say that's easy to do
when you're not stressed about money but
what can you do
I'm just trying to lighten up lighten up
for anyone that can I don't know well
you know someone made a good point that
I read they say you know you don't have
to be glued to the news cycle and to
Twitter you can just disconnect
Quarantine yourself and take this time
to learn a new skill you know take the
free like this unprecedented out of free
time like you've kind of forced to have
this time off right and be a home you
can do something with it I guess
stuff that you don't usually get the
chance to do but people who are worried
about money I am actually pleasantly
surprised at our government's response
to the to those people one being that it
looks like they're gonna put mortgage
payments and evictions on hold for now
they're actually gonna be implementing
some kind of ubi to pay everybody just
give everyone a check he says that's
coming within like two weeks and that
there's gonna be a lot of fallout I'm
not lying
when this thing goes away and then we
all kind of walk out of our fallout
Bunker's there's gonna be a lot of
problems to deal with a lot of debt the
ice I read that the this the one of the
Secretary of Commerce or employment or
whatever said that he's expecting like
20% unemployment during this time which
is like Great Depression era I mean
that's bad that's bad there's gonna
there's a lot we're gonna have to do is
but I think that you know on a larger
level sometimes shaking things up like
this come results and some good things
for example we obviously have some
fundamental issues with our society that
need to be addressed that this crisis is
illuminating for example ubi we need to
have a social safety net for people we
need to be more prepared for stuff like
this so I I'm hoping that at the end of
this becomes some some kind of positive
movements for the towards the betterment
of all people I wonder if people are
gonna get used to doing more stuff from
home afterwards even when they don't
need to like mmm working from home I
also wonder if people are gonna like is
this gonna kill shaking hands is this
gonna kill touchscreens you know for
example I go into bathrooms and they
don't have paper towels and you have to
open the door yeah that's the kind of
situation just sure I mean I know I
always felt crazy take the paper towel
you open the door but now it's not that
crazy is it no there are certain things
I feel like maybe maybe the party's over
in terms of just acting like like you
know ignoring contagion we need to be
smarter about how we pass on bugs to
each other I just feel like also for
anyone who wanted to pursue anything and
usually they don't have the opportunity
to like if you wanted to write something
a movie or a book or whatever or if
you're into gardening it's like you can
actually just do whatever you want for a
minute even though it's in a very dark
situation
and a dark setting well I always hear
this you probably heard it that like
Shakespeare wrote King Lear during
quarantine and Sir Isaac Newton
discovered a rope calculus during
quarantine and discovered gravity or
defined gravity which is like and for
example me like like both of those I am
going to get to 1,000 Paragon on Diablo
3 and I get on the leaderboard there you
go
so we all have our ambitions here folks
right that's right yeah what else I got
oh you want to see some depressing [ __ ]
Euler no no yeah I'm all right
yeah okay we talked about this oh this
shit's crazy Tom Hanks as you know got
coronavirus him and his wife or they're
in a Australia but that so he has a Tom
Hanks has a son named Chet who but most
of this video on Instagram let me just
show you this what's up everyone
oh yeah it's true my parents got
coronavirus crazy they're both down in
Australia right now because my dad was
shooting a movie down there but I just
got off the phone with them they both
are fine they're not even that sick
they're not worried about it they're not
tripping but they're going through the
necessary health precautions obviously
but I don't think it's anything to be
too worried about I appreciate
everyone's concern and the well wishes
but I think it's all going to be alright
well I appreciate it and everybody stay
safe out there
so I mean nice message yeah but
obviously how is this house don't hang
sign house like this I was like no way
this is how are they related [ __ ]
I was blown away by Chetniks because he
has his other son who's like an actor
Colin Hanks right and I was like yeah I
was like oh all of his kids look like
Colin Hanks
you know they all look like him like
he's like Tom Hanks junior he's all he's
like
sweet American boy actor looks just like
Tom Hanks caught but then you've got
Jack the rapper he's got Chet's got like
a urban kind of slang he'd talk he talks
like he's from the hood a little bit
yeah I was like Chet your Tom Hanks son
I mean but I guess look Tom it's got to
be tough being Tom Hanks son oh yeah you
know a man like damn you got to get some
it ain't you know it's but it's a big
spotlight to deal with so and it's in a
way I give it up to Chet for making a
unique persona for himself can't be easy
but that being said here he is we were
just looking at his Instagram and here
he is doing a Jamaican accent is on the
red carpet doing this man you know Tom
Hanks is gonna be like check can you not
do this on the red carpet sorry I just
realized how loud my water drinking was
oh you know he's like suck Chet I
appreciate the rapping
it's very supportive all I ask is that
you don't do the Jamaican accent on the
red carpet I'm Tom Hanks can we just not
do the Jamaican chat people I I'm super
supportive I love your music I just have
to say that you're making thing just I
don't want people to start talking and
on the red carpet and then shuts like
[ __ ] you dad he spells his last name
with the ex by the way H a and X I think
that's just a little gag I saw Tom Hanks
do it oh he did yeah oh oh it's like a
family thing maybe I'll kid cuz I think
when he announced the corona I think you
signed off Hanks oh I wonder if you got
that comes Chet because it's kind of
urban hip-hop it's your boy Chet Chet
Chet Chet is Chet short for something
anyway here's another one think it is I
don't remember what what could shet be
short for cheddar cheddar cheese
cheddar Hanks here's number two yellow
I'm just I just I'd do it all respect
and love to chat
I'm not putting your boy on blast like I
said I know ain't easy being Tom Hanks
on but I'm just shocked that this guy's
actually related to Tom Hanks okay no
here's another one because the youth
then we're at the Kings done wake up
this morning and we see the King tunnel
infinite but mad respek you don't know I
feel like he's been practicing that
quite a bit he got that down I gotta say
I'm impressed by his Jamaican he's on DJ
Cal level of Jamaican accent you know
it's got to be short for cheddar right
ILA's doing research do they bring the
drum roll back
the excitement attention so hard to find
you love I get stressed when I need to
read something on the show this chat
what is dad stand for Chester Oh Chester
Chester Hank's Chester's a nice name
that was stressful yeah I was getting
stressed so Chester Hank's there you go
now you learned something and finally
Jared Leto missed the corona virus
straight-up he was on a 12 day long MIDI
meditation vacation now if you don't
know about Jared Leto
he's like a cult leader he's an he hosts
a gathering for his band thirty Seconds
to Mars called Mars island he has
described it as a cult and I have to
admit that I also think that it is a
cult based on what I've seen here's a
tweet tweet it says oh yeah because yes
this is a cult
hashtag Mars Island so he was out in
like the desert with all of his freaky
white robe wearing why did they always
wear the same color like in every cult
yeah because it's not that I feel like
the cold is just not that original at
this point it's like we've seen it we
get it
how do people keep falling for this [ __ ]
but there you go and then look by the
way I love this photo yeah there's a
photo of him sitting with all this cult
members there in white and then there's
one dude here with a Marvel shirt it's
like one day you're gonna get a white
shirt for your cult meeting it's a
Marvel bro it's awesome it's like dude
you got to choose your like Alliance are
you thirty Seconds to Mars or are you
Marvel you can't do it both ways god
Jared what are you doing anyway here
look at this why do people need to call
it says so weird
you know this guy like you know this guy
Slams
yeah that's what it is that's basically
every cult leader it's like he wants to
have sex with everybody he wants to make
about your money
it's amazing um it's a credible this
whole cult phenomenon and it just keeps
happening but there you go it's Jared
Leto he's usually handsome charismatic
yada yada yada slammin that guy probably
is like a thousand kids so he missed the
whole coronavirus he just came out of
isolation and was like oh wow what's
going on here
nice hair let me see I've got the
tweezer I would okay bye
yo now you know at least nobody there
has the virus he says Wow 12 days ago I
began a silent meditation in the desert
we were totally isolated no phones no
communication etc we had no idea what
was happening outside the facility
walked out yesterday into a very
different world one that's been changed
forever mind-blowing to say the least
I'm getting messages from friends and
family all around the globe saying I
have your kid and you owe me child's no
heed they said and catching up on what's
going on you know he's got so many
bastards hope you and yours are okay
sending positive energy stay inside stay
safe Jared Leto everybody here is a
here's his website by the way I was kind
of curious so he has these shows thirty
Seconds to Mars here's what it costs to
get into a cult the Stargazer package
this is the most ghetto version three
nights all inclusive one payment of
1,600 or if you're broke and you want to
go pay to check to pay check three
hundred of six payments you've got
different levels here going all the way
up to you've got stargazer that's funny
that means you're just your ass is just
on the ground looking then the next one
is the adventure I mean it says
all-inclusive I don't know what that
means to McClaren probably festival
let's see style it includes festival of
full-length concert well okay
a solution wellness activities that
sounds like nothing
stay in air-conditioned - Bell tents
then accommodate for guests and have
access to shared modern facilities
including showers bathrooms which are
conveniently located okay so so you can
add on oh great you can add wait you
said all-inclusive you can add on early
entry for 5:50 you can get a tattoo for
a hundred dollars how the hell are you
gonna sell a mass tattoo
you ready trust some guy who's just come
intent to tank giving tattoos you think
that guys cleaning is needle
how funny a holistic massage ninety
dollars you know that's just some like
holistic how's that different than
normal massage it's called style
holistic it's somebody in a white garb
and dreadlocks is gonna do it deep
tissue massage for an extra five dollars
you can throw that in there ninety five
dollars so if I add all this time which
obviously I'm getting the tattoo this is
a good bargain 99 bucks
I know adults for a tattoo that's really
cheap mm-hmm they don't ask like how
many colors what is what am I getting
tattooed so now I'm up to 2500 months
that's not bad you know oh let me look
at pictures of it let's see what the
tent looks like so if Jared if you're
doing such a great cause for Humanity
why are you trying to make so much money
from this you know what I mean there's
the thing with coal heaters like yeah I
need to get rich and get laid all the
time by the way that looks like a
hellhole they're trying to make it look
nice but it really looks like a hellhole
so that is the Stargazer the next one is
the adventure mode so this one you're
gonna go do something see let's see what
the adventure package has this one
starts at $3,000 let's see adventure
package holders have shared ensuite
bathroom and shower facilities that's it
so they just have attached so they have
their own bathroom that's
have shared ensuite yeah what does that
mean shared with who's just not a tenth
it's just a little nicer looks like a
little structure yeah that's awesome I
love this let's see what else there is
this is total fire festival [ __ ] okay
they're like all-inclusive breakfast
lunch and dinner and then you just get
this ham sandwich oh no the wanderer
package $4,000 dude what do we get let's
see you get a state and air condition
forced lodge in the South camp that a
combo comma dates to package holders
have shared ensuite bathroom and shower
facility it said the same thing on the
other one what am I paying acts $4,000
for let's see by the way if you have to
do this in payments you really can't
afford it cheered really if you got to
do six payments of $600 because you
can't afford $4,000 that make sense to
me really but hold on we got the VIP
package weren't oh my god this one is
seven thousand over seven thousand
dollars whoa and then the Phoenix
package you're rising from the ashes
they don't even say the price they're
like it has a picture of him of Jared a
silhouette oh dude pay up and you can
hang out with our prophet here's the
daydreamer package $7,000
7150 dollars luxury awaits on the ion
this is so fire festival bro the VIP
package is located in sun lodges that
are completely waterproof i hope they're
waterproof damn why do you even have to
say that lockable no okay lockable and
fully furnished what they shared ensuite
bath you see a little more right you're
like bro
right so you cannot lock everything out
waterproof repair you better pray
doesn't rain available for two package
folders with either single or double bag
configuration some lodges are set inland
away from the coastal flooding
it says inland so I'm assuming close to
the kitchen and pool area providing
convenient and exclusive access to the
weekend festivals three night
all-inclusive festivals including two
full length concerts by thirty Seconds
to Mars as well as community and
wellness focused activities stay in a
shared occupancy air-conditioned Lodge
this mother-effer dude this is [ __ ]
and you still got to pay extra for the
tattoo so how much is that seven
thousand one hundred fifty dollars Wow
it's weather proofed and lockable and
it's it's located inside the coast you
don't get flooded that looks like a
[ __ ] if I'm being honest man what
what are they gonna do this a shed it's
a [ __ ] is it really a homeless man's
looks like we're all most people would
live I want to click this this one that
doesn't even list the price this is the
FINA SPAC egde ultimate luxury awaits
you picture yeah let's see what's the
difference the VIP package is located in
the private Sun lodges that are
completely weatherproof lockable and
fully furnished some so what is so they
don't offer they don't offer any here's
the VIP activities you ready for this
early entry priority entry VIP activity
with Jared Leto how much do we have to
pay I wonder how much this cost and even
listed they probably screen you based on
how good you look
yeah likely is to [ __ ] mother [ __ ] you
so you basically pay for Hammond and to
[ __ ] you that's just such a good racket
I wish I was good-looking enough
that people want to pay to have sex with
me let's see
barfle Cubans limited edition print I
don't know what that means
soundcheck what does that mean like
you're at the soundcheck the person that
does this sound check for us one two
check
did you get exclusive VIP merchandise
signed you know shows like a little
poster private boat dinner followed by a
private opening ceremony with the band
on an exclusive limited-edition gift
from jarrod and Shannon what private
transfer to and from the airport you
know that's just a school bus dude I'm
having total fire festival flashbacks
fridge stocked with beverages daily epic
private yoga sessions complimentary
massage oh well thank you
it's a comp it's complimentary massage
sixty minutes reserved water sports
equipment pool noodles reserved for you
complimentary snorkel equipment this is
so corny private family-style dining
breakfast lunch and dinner after show
late night food group concierge services
backstage tour from a crew member they
really this is crazy
please note each package includes a room
and board in your chosen accommodation
for the duration of the event rooms are
100% non-smoking passports or national
EU ID is required at check-in Mars
island is a festival with a community
and communal spirit please also be aware
mmm
what is the most what's written between
the lines they're basically saying if
you end up having to share us yeah
somebody crackers on your floor they're
like don't be a [ __ ] right this is a
cult if it's so communal and community
spirit why are you charging seven
thousand dollars that's very
capitalistic I want my own space
7,000 please also be aware that this is
luxury camping and the facilities are
high quality but are built to enhance
your experience of nature bro this is
the spirit of Mars family and we can't
wait to share with you wow this shit's
crazy who's that man you'd have to be
mint kind of mentally ill even want to
go to this it's in Croatia and you have
to fly your ass out to Croatia you see
there's a skeleton on the beach that's
what you're gonna be in like right so if
you go
I personally rather go to Brazos VIP
package instead of Mars Island so anyway
Jared Leto walked out and missed the
whole thing so there you have it welcome
to welcome to the apocalypse Jared it
was your fault you caused this in your
meditation and also interestingly
finally Big Brother there's all these
big brothers going on and they put them
in isolation and they have no idea
what's going on in the world I love that
so now but what about the crew the crew
that works they know they know yeah okay
I would assume yeah but I saw a clip of
one of the girls noticing that the live
audience was no longer there audience oh
my god
you know be awesome if if the crew
abandoned and then everyone was gone and
nobody told them and they keep on living
your life and Big Brother but nobody
tells them so what they're gonna do is
have a special livestream where they
tell them all what's going on and I have
to be honest I would watch that I don't
understand German obviously but I would
watch that
March 17th or just today did I miss it I
missed it haven't seen clips of this
right here's this girl talking about
yeah see you couldn't see yeah sitting
down right
eviction we heard people
unless the house is now sound higher
building the audience a little like all
people has an actual house I didn't
envision it as a set and then I came
here like all reliving in a set told him
to shut up
I don't watch this show it sounds crazy
I really want to watch the Big Brother
guys react to that but I don't know
where it is so there you go well that's
about all we've got here today this will
come out on Friday hopefully the world
is still we're filming this on Wednesday
so hopefully the world is still here on
Friday mm-hmm maybe Thursday I don't
know we'll see when it's ready cuz now
now what we have to do is we're gonna
send it to Dan he's gonna be has to put
in the videos cuz normally we would live
so H yeah so whatever we're watching the
live switch did that yeah so there's no
editing afterwards but now they're gonna
everything in yeah it's a lot more
complicated so it may take a little
extra time that's why we say Friday so
we are swell so yeah doesn't come out
Friday and um hopefully this was
watchable
it was great this is come on better than
nothing can we say that yeah better than
nothing that's a low bar well that's the
bar that said right now there's nothing
going on better than nothing well this
was a weird app because it was all words
like I can't ignore I can't ignore the
coronavirus yeah and um well I'll tell
you what else the other reason was the
challenging you guys will know sim but
you know why Oh think about it okay yeah
it's very challenging we can talk about
it next episode okay but I think we did
fine mm-hm
you know so this is the quarantine zone
how's it sound how does it look right
how does it compare that's what I would
like to know and did you laugh did you
smile did you think did you wonder what
it means to be human
on a planet here we are a collective we
are a hive we must band together to
survive or be our own demise well
there's the Great Firewall they say they
say do alien civilizations evolved to go
interplanetary and our galactic and they
say well maybe none do maybe we're the
most advanced maybe there's a great
firewall that prevents species from
evolving to that point one of them we
could be experiencing now as a pandemic
the next one could be far worse and if
we don't get wiser and learned from this
we may never venture to the stars think
about that right you want to go to the
stars yeah we're not there you know I
want I just want to have my brain beamed
up to the top pictures of Mars today
from Elon Musk really I didn't see those
they got a cool panoramic are they in
Mars he's got a bot on Mars or what yeah
you can open this Twitter oh that's kind
of cool I just woke up oh my go okay
here's pictures of Mars on Twitter it
looks like Earth it looks like the
desert whenever I see pictures of Mars
on my table in there its Mojave Desert
oh here we go he retweeted something
curiosity Mars rover
oh that's NASA's ship successful
deployment of sixty starling satellites
confirmed are you talking about this
video this is from curiosity this is
NASA's Mars rover we're able to capture
the rover using the other mask embolism
my
the higher resolution version is nearly
1.8 billion pixels yeah what I gotta
mute it sorry oh wow that's some high
def yeah yeah that's pretty cool it's
like yeah that's a lot everything but
you know what I mean I was like [ __ ]
I've been there before we shut our
camping video oh hey guys
yeah Vegas pretty much Wow
I'm more impressed by the high
definition of that photograph alright
enjoy the quarantine everybody let's not
let I will try not to talk about it
anymore now here we are here to
entertain we are not here to politicize
we are not here to kvetch or to complain
we're here to make your existence on
this earth a more pleasant one so from
here on out burying something absolutely
catastrophic that we absolutely cannot
simply resist talking about we will
avoid a corona based topics
what do we call this episode pastry
podcasts forever a street podcast never
dies pastry podcasts quarantine zone the
show must go on
[Music]
flatten the curve baby alright that's it
stay blessed